Hi! This video is about the /ə/ sound.
A common challenge with the /ə/ sound...
...is that the speaker will sometimes move the sound forward.
So a word like "but" sounds like "bit".
Now, let's practice.
Place your tongue behind your lower front teeth and stretch from the back.
That's the /ə/ sound.
Now let's practice with a few words...
...and notice the /ə/ sound is in unstressed syllables.
Here is the /ə/ when it starts a word.
Apply,..
...observe,...
...admire,...
...again,...
...awake,...
...achieve.
Now let's try the /ə/ in the middle of a word.
...Automatic,...
...meditate,...
...manicure,...
...capacity,...
...California.
Now let's give it a shot at the end of a word and keep it nice and easy!
India,...
...Sherpa,...
...pasta,...
...data,...
...soda.
You may have noticed that the /ə/ sound can actually be spelled in English...
...with several different letters including "i", "a", and "o".
So put this into play as you practice on EnglishCentral and good luck!